I didn't ask to be the one to talk about
the chosen one trope
I didn't want to be the one to talk
about it
but I'm the only one who can do it
[Music]
yeah that that opening was a joke I hope
you realize so yes I want to talk about
a Trope and in this case I want to talk
about the Trope of chosen ones and I
will tip my hand really early this is
basically going to be an extended
justification for why I really don't
care for chosen one stories
I don't
and I'm gonna try and explain why so
that it doesn't just come across as me
just poo pooing an idea there are
reasons that it bothers me as much as it
does again with many tropes for its
ubiquity and overuse as opposed to the
idea inherently inherently there isn't a
lot wrong with the idea in Practical
matters and especially how often it
shows up in various forms I really
I do not care for it very much at all uh
the timing of this largely has to do
with we are very soon going to be
getting the Doctor Who Centenary special
power of the doctor and given that it is
the final appearance of Jody Whitaker's
13th doctor in addition to the title
that has been given for that it leads me
to think that it is going to be touching
on and wrapping up the stuff dropped in
the Timeless children which is
effectively a chosen one story which
should bring me to the first thing that
I should clarify just to deal with the
pendants in the audience so that you get
off my back
not every chosen one is literally chosen
to explain that some chosen ones the
choosing of them is incredibly literal
in the sense that they are assigned
their role of importance by some higher
authority some Mentor figure even or
some kind of choosy artifact that is in
some way going to tip the balance of
whatever the events are going on those
are your most literal forms of Chosen
One others are functionally chosen ones
in that the narrative functions the
exact same way as if they had been
literally chosen even though nobody
actually pointed them and went you are
the chosen one and that's where the
doctor falls in she is effectively a
chosen one or to take something like the
original Dark Crystal film a character
like Jen is basically a Chosen One by
default because the prophecy and that's
another thing I'm gonna have to touch on
because I don't like prophecies either
either but the reasons I don't
prophecies and chosen ones are very
nested subjects so we are going to be
covering both
um but the reason Jen is kind of the
hero there is because the prophecy
that's in play says that a gelfling will
bring about the reunion of The Shard to
the rest of the Crystal and he is at
least at the start of the film so far as
we're aware the last golfing alive so he
is The Chosen One by default without any
prophecy actually naming him in specific
and the doctor is a little bit similar
she is functionally a chosen one because
as was revealed in the Timeless children
she is so far as we are currently aware
absolutely unique and her very existence
reshaped the entire course of the
universe
that effectively narratively makes her
function as a chosen one again even
though nobody specifically selected her
and said this is your destiny
so
what's wrong with chosen ones well
actually let's back up why would you do
a chosen one story well there's a number
of reasons at this point Chosen One
deconstructions are not particularly
uncommon you can oftentimes have a
villain that was a previous chosen one
but they turned out to not be uh the
actual one who should have been doing
that thing or sometimes a villain might
be driven to villainy because they
thought they deserved to be the chosen
one and then that didn't happen so
chosen ones can not only impact the
heroes but also you can build your
villains around it you can have
deconstructions about it you can have
your story be about the chosen one
really not wanting to be the chosen one
fighting against it trying to dodge the
responsibility but ultimately
what I don't like about chosen one's
stories
is they basically tell you at the front
end or at whatever point the chosenness
is established
what the overall thing is going to be
and what really matters now this is a
personal preference
I enjoy over the course of a story
discovering what it's really about
because a story might have a surface
level of an initial conflict or an
internal conundrum for a character but
then by the time it's over you realize
okay that was going on but it was really
about some other stuff and you can go
metaphorical with that or it can turn
out it literally there's just other
stuff going on
but what chosen ones and prophecies do
is they lay out hey no matter what else
goes on over the course of the story
whether we're talking a movie a TV
series or a long-running book series no
matter what else we deal this
this character and or this prophecy this
is what the story is really about and
it's what we're ultimately going to
circle back to to deal with which first
of all often to me at least feels like
it diminishes the importance of
basically every other character and
every other event that doesn't tie
directly into the chosen one of the
prophecy that's just stuff that happens
along the way now if you do it well you
can still get people invested in those
other characters and those other events
I'm not saying it's impossible to do a
chosen one story well
so don't think that I hate all of them I
am however deeply sick of them because
they robbed me of the discovery of what
this is going to be and what direction
it's going to go when something
announces a chosen one or lays out a
prophecy that is the story telling me
that's where we're going and I'm just
gonna go oh
okay uh I I it would have been nice to
realize on my own where this was going
not everyone enjoys that some people
want to know where are things going and
that's valid this is my personal issues
with the Trope they don't have to be
yours and if you actually find a benefit
in knowing ultimately what the story is
going to have to deal with by the end
regardless of what else goes on and that
makes it easier for you to enjoy awesome
it just doesn't for me there's also a
very common issue with chosen ones in
that it flattens the characters and it
removes the need to justify a lot of
either the characters decisions or the
the general rolling out of the narrative
it robs those things of their own agency
because now it's Destiny and at its
worst
you end up with characters that if they
weren't the chosen one if they weren't
basically assigned the role of
protagonist by narrative declaration
you wouldn't really care or be following
this person
it's often leaned on as a reason to
under characterize or at least take your
sweet time bothering to characterize
your lead character
because you don't have to explain why
they're on this Quest why they
personally have a character-based reason
to want to fight this evil why they are
wrapped up in all this and why they they
don't make the twist just run away it
removes your obligation to justify any
of those things with a character-based
reason because you can just go well
Chosen One it often feels like a cheat
and unless you are going to build the
entire story around it and even then
you're not necessarily going to get me
on board but unless you're building the
entire story around it it more often
than not just feels like a means to
justify why this person is the
protagonist rather than anybody else
and this is particularly why prophecies
and chosen one stories can bother me the
later into an overall narrative that
they get introduced because if we're
talking say a TV series if we're
multiple seasons in and then suddenly we
drop a prophecy and or Chosen One
that's not what this has been up to now
and now all of a sudden you're going and
we have now designated the single most
important person
I've never taken well to that I've never
taken well to the sense that a writer or
a writing team or what have you is
telling me
who I should care about
I'm not going to argue who the
protagonist of a story is the
protagonist is whoever you make it but
like
to basically make it a narrative decree
this is the most important person and
you should care
I kind of instinctively want to fight
against that and go yeah but why and
again it very often to me feels like an
excuse for why the lead isn't anybody
else other than who we have or in the
case of the doctor it's very weird
because the doctor was always the most
interesting thing going on in their
stories
and then they made them a chosen one
anyway which is
it's still such a bizarre
choice to me okay I need to not dwell on
that I'm sure I'll have plenty to say
about the doctor and the Timeless child
thing
when power of the doctor comes out so I
just I should table that for now but
sort of coming back to what I said
before about how chosen ones and
prophecies lay out for you what this is
going to be about and where it's going
it also for me feels like it Narrows
down the possibilities that could happen
now broadly speaking if you're in a sort
of traditional conflict good guys versus
bad guys there's honestly only two
primary ways that things could go down
the good guys win or the good guys lose
but those two things can take a lot of
shapes and good guys lose rarely happens
if we're being honest but in terms of
good guys win there's still a lot that
can happen they win at what cost what
did they lose along the way did they win
partially or fully and the thing about a
chosen one and a prophecy is it lays out
the specific conditions
so it's not just this is the person
fated to be involved in a final Conflict
it is laying out the conditions for what
victory looks like and that also applies
to even vager prophecies that are like
oh we know it will all center around
this person they will either save us
or destroy us well the general tone of
the work up to that point should tell
you which is the more likely from a
narrative perspective
so even that still feels like it's
narrowing down the possibilities because
once you open up the can of worms that
is a chosen one or a prophecy there's
surprisingly few worms in there I don't
know why I'm sticking with the worms
thing but here we go there is the
prophecy goes through basically as
written the chosen one does exactly what
the chosen one has been predicted to do
next up and I would say increasingly
common the prophecy does come true or
the chosen one does do what it said
they're going to do but not in the way
that most of the characters involved
were expecting this is oftentimes where
you get
um the sort of self-fulfilling prophecy
things where like a villain accidentally
causes the prophecy that's going to
defeat them to come true or things of
that nature so that's just two
variations of Prophecy comes true and
it's pretty rare
for prophecy or chosen one to Simply
not do the thing
but that's kind of the only other option
but again
almost never happens
one way to make this pattern less
obvious than it normally is is to do
what Aladdin did and that is have a
chosen one who does the chosen thing
early in the movie I wonder how many
people even remember that Aladdin is a
chosen one because he's the only one who
can enter the Cave of Wonders but he
does that a half hour into a 90-minute
movie and so after that prophecy is
fulfilled and the movie can go in any
direction that is kind of a neat have
your cake and eat it too option that you
don't see often because most stories
hinge their finales on the chosen one or
the prophecy and another things that
really bothers me about
um chosen one and prophecy narratives
is a failure to establish
why the authority that this prophecy or
choosing is coming down from should be
believed or trusted now this applies in
more literally chosen characters as
opposed to characters chosen by default
so this is something that actually
bugged me in the end of time that's the
Doctor Who two-parter that ended David
Tennant's initial run as the doctor and
that is that the time Lords are
operating on the basis of a prophecy now
the time Lords depending on when you are
watching Doctor Who either are very
mysterious or are surprisingly
pedestrian but this whole idea of this
more mystical aspect is not something
that's really seriously rooted in most
of the Canon material by Canon I mean
the TV show the various things like
novels comics and whatever are basically
Canon until they're not because the show
is not obligated aided to hold true to
them so part of why that really bothered
me was that since mysticism of that kind
wasn't really firmly established as
being part of Time Lord culture again
not in the show and certainly not in the
revived version of the show up to that
point the idea of just injecting a
prophecy my first question is
why why do you believe this falling all
of it falling
black and pitch and screaming fire so
burning why are you assuming the
correctness of that and most stories
don't bother to establish that now
sometimes it doesn't matter sometimes
all that matters is that certain
characters believe it now this usually
works better if it is the villain who
believes it so to come back to say The
Dark Crystal which uh if you hadn't
guessed is an example I am leaning on
rather heavily to avoid having to bring
up Harry Potter because otherwise that
would be a one that I could cite readily
in this but I don't want to
um but in the Dark Crystal again the
thing that matters is less that the
prophecy is absolutely true that all the
that a gelfling will end them then the
fact that the skeksis believed that
enough
to wipe out the gelflings or at least
try to
so that is a situation where maybe the
prophecy is true maybe it's not but the
actions of the villains who absolutely
believed it pushed the story forward now
that doesn't suddenly make me like that
because again that kind of falls into
the villains accidentally caused the
prophecy themselves sort of thing but
again to come back to where I was at a
minute ago
what is establishing this Authority
there's always this notion of these
ancient Scrolls these ancient things the
or you know somebody who is all this
power declares this or that or this will
happen or this person has a prophecy or
like there's almost no real examination
of where these prophecies and where
these means to choose someone even come
from and why they have authority
some
some will engage with that question and
actually have characters push back on it
although most often it comes in the
shape of the chosen one really not
wanting to be chosen so they push back
on the idea but when that happens
usually nobody else does and so it's
very clearly not a genuine attempt to
push back or Justify the authority of
the prophecy or the chosen one
perspective but instead is uh attempt to
give some kind of Arc to a character who
basically has had their entire Arc
already laid out for them most the ones
that I can think that do question this
are comedies like The Lego Movie It
ultimately still pans out that Emmett
who was misidentified as the chosen one
does ultimately save the day in a manner
very unique to him so even though that
prophecy gets called out as BS it still
functions narratively the exact same as
a prophecy that gets fulfilled in a
non-standard way and I can't think of
any non-comedic attempts to bring it to
question the validity of a prophecy so
what I would honestly you know what I'd
love
it would be awesome
if like some characters were
given a a prophecy or like told it's
this and
somebody within the group somebody that
who has established Authority who the
audience or the readers or the viewers
or whatever has a reason to believe in
Trust
like reads out this prophecy or finds
out it's something that's guiding the
actions of somebody villains or Heroes
and then just scoffs crumples it up and
throws it away you're like
that's just some random nonsense
somebody wrote down
Because unless you justify why this is
correct
yeah it's some random nonsense somebody
wrote down
and again some things do engage a little
bit or at least try and create within
their settings a reason why the source
is something to be believed but much
like not needing to justify the actions
of your hair anymore once they are
designated protagonist by default a lot
will just not bother
the word prophecy comes up and because
of the narrative way in which prophecies
are used I.E to lay out how things are
supposed to go from here on out with
only the slight variations that I talked
about already then there's just an
expectation that the audience they know
how prophecies work we've told them this
is a prophecy doing a prophecy story now
but that's a meta-justification so if
you bother to actually justify and
grapple with it in Universe in narrative
so again it feels like a means to skip a
lot of steps to gloss over a lot of
stuff and I'm not even going to say that
that is an inherently bad thing because
sometimes if you're telling a certain
story there are certain things that just
don't interest you as a Storyteller that
you don't want to have to deal with or
you can't figure out an interesting way
to justify and so you take a shortcut
and that's the thing for me in the end
chosen ones and prophecies feel like
shortcuts and I understand why shortcuts
exist and I'm not going to say there's
never a reason to use them
but when it seems like the shortcut gets
used over and over and over and over
again well that's just becoming just
another standard path isn't it
prophecies chosen ones they are
narrative tools that from my experience
are used in
frustratingly limited ways because there
are more things that could be done with
these than usually are but as with most
tropes generally once invoked there's a
very clear funnel that this story and
these characters are now going to go
down and it's one I've seen and read and
heard and am at this point very
very bored by I want to see a story that
unravels because the characters make
decisions that make sense to them not
because Destiny has put its hand on the
scale
when I was younger I had more of
appreciation of a sense of Destiny and
fate and it still can work especially if
you're going with a little bit of a
tragic angle because I can think back to
this is going to be a weird movie to
pull but I'll mention it anyway one of
the things I really enjoyed about seeing
Peter Jackson's King Kong in the theater
was that it played best assuming you
knew how the original King Kong went and
so there was a sense of tragic
inevitability to it
kind of in the way how Romeo and Juliet
starts by a narrator literally telling
you this will end in both characters
deaths so you already know where it's
going and so the tragedy comes in
watching people try to avoid this but
you know it's coming anyway and I did
once have an appreciation for that
I've lost it and maybe it's age
bitterness maybe it's you know having
spent enough time doing my own writing
to just see how much of a easy cheat it
can be if you don't seriously explore
the concepts but for whatever reason
I'm over it
I hear the word prophecy I see a
character functionally become a Chosen
One by structure of the narrative or by
re oftentimes by reveal of their past I
kind of check out mentally
I'm just bored
I've seen this story I played this game
and I'm not saying it was never good
but I'm done I'm over it
and maybe others are too
or maybe others deeply love Chosen One
stories and in the latter case I hope
you can now at least understand a little
better why I don't and again
I know I said it during the thing I'm
not saying there is no such thing as a
good chosen one story most tropes are
not a problem in and of themselves they
are a problem as they become standard as
they become common as they become
so clearly used the same way pretty much
every time with little variation or in
the case of this as we have entered the
area the era of trying to subvert chosen
when expect expectations very formulaic
deviations
I think that's the thing chosen ones
feel so played out to me at this point
that even if it tries to subvert the way
the chosen one story works I still feel
like I already know what that's going to
look like and I'd just rather not
I would just rather not
you know this is part of why when I sat
down eventually and wrote my own fantasy
novel uh linked to buy that in the
description I focused on what I
considered small people in a big world
because when you deal with prophecies
and chosen ones you are dealing with the
people who reshape
everything
you are dealing with the names that will
be remembered by history and I think
being tired of that is part of why when
I wrote dreams of fire I'm like I am
focusing on people who will never get
more than a tiny footnote in a history
book
because
ultimately they're not important from
any Grand historical or mythical
perspective
but they still have good stories to tell
that's where I'm at in
my hopes I can still find some enjoyment
of stories of grand figures
but if we could keep the chosen Oneness
out of that I'll have a better chance of
enjoying those things
so that's me
has anything that I've said made any
kind of sense to you are you where I'm
at are you somewhere else do you think
what I said makes no sense whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments and let us talk about it
patreon is what pays the bills enables
me to do this as my living spend my time
thinking about these things thinking
about how I want to share these things
with you and also gave me enough time to
you know actually get my freaking book
published so there's a lot that is able
to happen because of the support on
patreon even if you're not able to help
me that way uh likes your subscribe also
are of great assistance
at the end of all this though what I
really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm only running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lafolla Tarak the theme that goes doink
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leota Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobelax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperal
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay Brendan
Larose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out
thanks so much you are a pain in my butt
[Music]